the Joe Rogan experience soft fight at
Disneyland on Instagram the other day
the Jews were going out on Disneyland
some got punched a check to see Google
Finland two people were filming that
these people were throwing down in front
of their kids at Disneyland Oh terrible
technique - everybody's terrible
terrible I love that the the equally
disappointing aspect of it well it's
terrible it's the most disappointing
it's like guys if you're gonna fight
learning technique yeah I mean it's like
someone's stealing the stage and playing
bad guitar you'd be angry with yes sir
see what I'm saying yeah I get it no I'm
in complete agreement I think that that
is kind of equally important because hey
man if people are filming yeah people
like a consensual fight you look like
you're trying to pretend you know how to
fight yeah and that the worst is the
pulling off of the shirt I don't even
know how that even becomes like an
instinct it's actually a good move well
it's to keep you slippery right so you
can like well you want yeah you don't
want anybody choking you to death with
your own jacket oh that's true yeah
that's true well okay but I mean I guess
in the videos that I've seen it's been
mostly about like hey check out jack bro
yeah yeah and here did I kind of like
this dude got choked out but I couldn't
quite tell what was going on here cuz he
went down quick cuz that security anyone
hasn't been out for a second so he's
pulling that girl's hair
see oh yeah oh she dropped him his head
banged off the ground to that ball dude
choked the [ __ ] out he's like well I
just killed a guy I better get out of
here I think but you know every joke no
charges were pressed because no one
wanted to say what the fight was about
hilarya was that so it was a guy that
was holding a girl's hair at the end
yeah I said he got spit on and then he
went crazy Wow I don't know if that was
the whole thing and then funny that's
all it takes a little bit of water a
little bit of yeah it's funny if I got
all the things that make people go crazy
spit in someone's face is like wow war
here yeah I mean it's it is pretty not a
prude biological weapon back in the day
if you had some way smallpox is a [ __ ]
yeah how dare you potentially infect me
[Applause]